DeSantis and Gavin Newsom are going to
be having their own quasi-presidential
debate moderated by Sean Hannity here is
DeSantis on the debate it's an important
debate for the country not like saying
who's better Florida California because
that debate is over because people have
voted with their feet they've left
California and come to Florida not the
other way around he has lost massive
amounts of population no governor in
California history has ever witnessed
population loss at all on net and he's
had it and Greg because it's because of
the policies he's driving people away
but what's the future for the country
the future for the country uh for what
the left would want to do is just double
down on the California policies and so
and it's he's absolutely right too about
the debate the debate has already been
settled the U-Hauls are moving from
California to Florida not the other way
around